antoine que peut-on attendre du futur
relations entre la nouvelle
administration américaine et le kremlin
oui bien l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche est attendue avec un brin
de fatalisme à moscou il arrive en effet
avec certains membres de son équipe qui
faisait déjà partie de l'administration
obama et qui n'ont pas laissé que des
bons souvenirs en russie par exemple
avec l'intervention militaire de l'otan
en libye vécu comme une humiliation du
côté des russes et depuis la défaite
d'hillary clinton lors de l'élection
présidentielle américaine de 2016 avec
les accusations d'ingérence russe les
démocrates ont tendance à tenir la
russie pour responsable de tous leurs
malheurs
cette dernière polémique vient de
nouveau l'illustré dans des propos
partagés avec nancy pelosi la présidente
de la chambre des représentants
hillary clinton estime que vladimir
poutine pourrait bien être derrière les
événements du capitole le genre
d'accusations infondées qui hérite
particulièrement les autorités russes
quoi qu'il en soit du côté de moscou
on ne s'attend pas à de grands
bouleversements dans les relations entre
les deux pays et coûté on voit que la
politique de domination de l'état
américain ainsi que leur mode de vie et
compréhension de la vie des autres pays
qui se poursuivra la dissuasion envers
la chine et la russie figurera
certainement à l'ordre du jour de la
politique étrangère quant à la politique
à l'égard de la russie
j'ai l'impression que les manières
seront peut être un peu plus courtoise
mais les changements dans l'essence même
de leur politique sont peu probables
pour mot ce cours là bien entendu il est
possible qu'il y ait quelques
changements sur la forme comparé à
l'administration trump mais sur le fond
cela va vrai sens vraisemblablement être
la même chose il ya tout de même un peu
plus d'optimisme concernant la
renégociation de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien et la renégociation
des grands traités de limitation des
armements stratégiques de dossiers sur
lesquels joe biden a laissé la porte
entrouverte
merci antoine claireaux pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de moscou en russie
banquiers